Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Oh yeah.
But the kitchen like him more to
measure the opponent of the bay and then
suddenly his his hand.
So
he's the guy,
man.
He's one of my favorite guys to watch.
Also be outside of fighting
the way he talks.
He never has the same like with me,
but the interviews,
when people ask you know about your life,
how it started?
Well it,
it's,
it's the same story over and over again.
Well he,
he can,
he can make it every time.
He's one of those guys
have constantly changes.
Smart businessman.
Yeah.
Oh,
smart.
Smartest.
He's the best shit talker and
the history of combat sports.
Before that it was like chill son and,
and Muhammad Ali and now
it's kind of aggressive.
He just knows how to fucking say it.
Jeremy Stevens starts talking and he goes,
the guy just destroyed
them with one sentence.
He's,
he finds the perfect shit.
The way he looked back.
It's hilarious.
I mean when he went in there and
I related Eddie Alvarez like that,
you just kind of go,
Ooh,
fuck you man.
Yup.
He's any of that style of
sliding out and sliding in.
It's a very unusual,
almost a karate based style.
Yep.
And I went to like sitting down on
vicious punches on the end of it,
you know,
but he,
his stamps and because
she's just softball.
But I,
I thought,
you know,
with,
with the Aldo,
if I was all those coach
a year ago already,
I would have said we got to tray South
Pole and go because there's no way he can
block those low kicks,
his left low kicks Gump.
There's no way he can block them because
his stance is too white and his knees
are pointing inside to the shadow.
The chem 100% of that is the
whole game changes the whole game.
And his left low kicked by the way,
look,
although could kick the fuck out of you
with either low low kicks her right.
Wow Man.
Yeah,
he's a,
he,
he always made me think it for
Ramon Dekkers that explosive.
Oh Man.
His law will,
they'd call the Duchy left to the body
and then right leg kick behind it.
Chad Mendez.
I was like,
Woo though.
He throws it man.
I think Aldo and Max Holloway
a very interesting fight.
It has to happen.
I keep hearing all this crazy shit like
all my go up and fight a bead for the
interim title and I'm like,
God damn it.
You got to have money.
Why don't I,
well there we go again.
Right.
The money wait fights everyone
already even that talked about
away instead of staying in their
way instead of defending the title,
they old.
It's obviously not as big a fight.
Is Him Fighting Nemo Grumet
off in Russia though,
right?
Especially if they fight
for a 55 pound title.
If nerveracking Madoff fights in Russia,
they might have to fucking
build a new soccer state yet.
I don't think people understand.
Anytime I post something on Instagram,
I get 150 fucking Russian dudes who write
Habib time and then they just pulled a
beep time and the credits,
what fucking credits are overrun with
people that say or a not credits,
comments rather overrun with people.
Say Habib time.
Habib Tom [inaudible] fucking just for
safety when they're building that thing.
Make an underground tunnel when he loses
Kop we straight to the airport sites.
Connor,
you know what's interesting about the
Conor fight man lock Habib Time Habib Tom
See?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's not fucking around.
It's all true.
But like,
um,
if he fights Connor,
we,
Michael Johnson cracked
him and rocked him.
I went,
oh boy.
Did he get it?
He did get angry.
He beat the fuck out of them yet.
But the point is he got hurt.
He got hurt.
And if Connor catches you like that,
you might be fucking Donesville.
Yup.
He might drop some hammers on you
and that might be the same thing,
right.
The uh,
you know,
we seen caught or as
well at times it's just,
well,
Ben,
Ben Shahn Habib's defense,
we saw Conor get rocked against Nate
and he wound up losing that fight.
Shortly thereafter.
Habib got rocked and it's
Michael Johnson back.
Came back stronger.
Yeah.
Dominated him.
So it was the only time,
I mean,
it's,
when you see a guy who
his dominant is a B,
you start looking for
weaknesses in his arm.
It's the only time we've
seen any weakness at all.
Yeah.
But Mcgregor to,
in his defense,
he was getting tired already there.
You're ready?
Yup.
Yup,
Sure.
That'd be,
it doesn't get tired.
Yeah.
Okay.